Troy Polamalu now a pro Football Hall of
Famer look at Troy joins us now
Troy congratulations the most important
question is how's the hair that's
getting maybe a little bit more gray but
still soft and lump luscious as possible
so okay how's your hair gonna look on
the bust at in Kenton I don't know we're
still really working through that right
now the bus really has I don't think
we've cast anything yet so I still have
a couple more meetings to figure it all
out but would you do hair down would
Troy Polamalu do a hair bun most
definitely hair down I very rarely water
down so game days were pretty much the
only days in commercial days as well so
most definitely down when I Taylor
called you baby Jesus why did he
nickname you that honestly I don't
really know I think a lot of different
reasons why but you know they just
definitely have we have so much respect
for each other as brothers and as
teammates at times I may be served as
you know some of my brother's conscience
at times as well so I'm not sure the
reason why exactly do you feel different
as a hall-of-famer no to be big to be
frank not really I'm definitely very
grateful and blessed but to me to just
really more of a tribute to my teammates
I'm and and obviously the great coach
and coach LeBeau and coach Tomlin coach
kara that I've been a part of I've been
a part of a you know arguably one of the
most dominant defensive runs that the
game has seen so just having those sort
of great team mates throughout my whole
career - it's more or less a tribute to
them best player you ever played against
wow there's so many what's really funny
is as later in my career as I continue
to watch more more football you know
watching a great receiver the tio the
Randi monsters and whatnot I actually
started to be more impressed with myself
so I was amazed that I was able to you
know share the field with some of these
tremendous great athletes but you know
there's physical specimens like Calvin
Johnson that you know arguably could
have been the most dominant receiver in
the history of this game
you know there's great running backs
Adrian Peterson there's great
quarterbacks obviously the you know Tom
and Peyton Aaron Rodgers so I've been
very very blessed and fortunate to to be
able to experience the field against
them you ever think back on that I'm
sorry I definitely have to add as well
that I played against Jerry Rice had to
play against Marshall Faulk you know I
meant like so to be able to almost cross
a couple generations is a it's pretty
awesome as well when so much time you
thought back to that draft night when
the Steelers traded up they traded when
they traded the 27th overall pick a
third and sixth round that the Chiefs
you know the Steelers can thank the
Chiefs for trading to them because they
took you like 15 or 16 in that draft
didn't they yeah that's right it was a
taxi pretty funny story I was a you know
obviously went to USC hoping to stay in
Southern California and I get this for
when to area code which is not a
Southern California or California area
code and my heart does drop I was like
oh gosh where in the world am I going
now so I get this call from coach Cowher
which is funny because we thought we
spent some time together of his last few
weeks together and I was just talking we
were just joking about the fact that you
know a culturally Pittsburgh is very
different from Southern California and
of course the weather is as well but
what you know what became a fear of mine
truly became a home to me I had lived in
Pittsburgh longer I lived anywhere in my
life my children are born there so I
live I love that city and it's there in
my heart if you were playing now in your
prime what would you do against Patrick
mahomes
man you know there's so many younger
quarterbacks that are coming out are so
athletic so dynamic and you know the way
they're able to throw and spin the ball
the way that they're able to be multi
you know have these multi threats as
well as the way the game has evolved and
you know spreading out and in all of
these different place and misdirections
it's you know when you defend somebody
like Patrick or or the quarterback of in
Baltimore Lamar Jackson
yeah Lamar Jackson it's such a it's such
a team decent and that's kind of why I
go back to the way that we play defense
in Pittsburgh is men it really I was
just one of eleven roles within our
defense and it really took a collective
effort to to you know for us to be
really successful so when you talk about
these younger talents that are that's
you know that awesome that it really
would just take a true team defense and
a genius like coach Dabo to guide us how
would you have to change with today's
hitting in the NFL I man some sometimes
you just have the style of play that's
within you and you know you just have to
roll with some of the punches that could
you change and whatever you do across
the way no I uh yeah absolutely it's you
know it's professional athletes you have
to change it's really tough but you know
sometimes when when you're forced to
make conscious decisions when many
things out they're very instinctual you
know it would it you know there's
definitely a learning process there it
was back in July of 2012 you joined us
and I asked how many concussions you had
had and you made some headlines this is
a portion of that response that you gave
me back then well I had I believe eight
or nine recorded concussions we'll have
another conversation after I'm done
playing football well here we are Troy
well that was so memorable I totally
forgot the number and the conversation
joking how many concussions do you think
you had yes the same number okay be
honest I didn't have any more after that
that IRA can recall us but I will
definitely say that it you know the
lifestyle that you live while playing
football is definitely devoted to health
and wellness and doing everything
possible to keep not only your body your
joints and all that healthy but your
brain healthy or cognitive functions
healthy so my lifestyle hasn't changed
since I was done playing you know very
been proactive and health and wellness
eating correctly hydrating doing
cognitive brain games and these sort of
things so I think God haven't had any
sort of issues up to this point but I
definitely attribute that of course to
the blessings but the fact that I've
been very aggressive towards you know
maintaining a health and wellness
program since my playing days what would
you tell a 21 22 year-old Troy Polamalu
how a man honestly nothing I'm so
grateful for for for everything that
I've you know experienced in my life my
children my wife
I truly am really grateful and and at
times I feel like maybe I don't live my
life to agree a degree of gratitude that
I've been fortunate enough to have but I
you know I honestly would maybe just say
take it all in appreciate more of the
process you know throughout the whole
grind for me you know I didn't take any
vacations so I retired for example you
know and and now you know we have these
sort of opportunities with my wife and
my children but I probably would have
taken maybe a vacation here and there
you know throughout throughout my career
to provide a little bit more balance but
to this day I'm truly grateful for all
the experience that I've had what's the
last time you wanted to hit somebody
tackle
but man that last game I really don't
miss missed the game or being on the
field at all I was fortunate fortunate
enough to watch the Superbowl as well
which was the first live football game
that I'd experienced that I didn't play
in so I didn't really miss that all the
things that I do miss were we're like
the you know of course the locker room
banter just being around the guys but
from a personal note it was just
training I really really enjoyed you
know the voting you know as a job for
myself to to just work on myself to
being a better football player to
getting healthy to to you know being
mentally and emotionally balanced and
and really being paid for that you know
now now I have to kind of squeeze in my
workouts you know like between like you
know dropping off my kids in school and
in doing whatever errands I need to do
for my wife and for the you know for the
house we live in so it's not so much of
a priority but it's definitely something
that I do every day every time I talk to
you I say the same thing or when people
here you want to show they say the same
thing if I didn't know what you did for
a living I certainly couldn't tell by
your voice yeah I don't know I can't
sing at all it's awful
it leads to any but if you didn't play
football
what would you be what would you have
done I don't know I think the beautiful
thing about football is that the skill
set that requires you to be a good
football player could really transfer to
anything you know that's what I'm
starting to figure out now is that you
know the sort of dedication to hard work
you know the sacrifice the sort of
commitment you know using these
qualities of teammates and leveraging
each other to attain a certain goal
these sort of you know these sort of
qualities really can transfer to
anything so I I you know maybe could say
that I you know didn't matter if I
wanted to be a doctor or to be a lawyer
or to be you know a baseball player I
felt like you know the attributes that
help you to be a good full
while player transfer I just feel like
I'd walk into a surf shop or a
skateboard shop and you'd be there
behind the counter oh yeah I that that
could be me anything from well I
definitely enjoy the wave surfing
currently live in San Diego love
snowboarding definitely like being part
of the outdoors and and pretty much
doing anything that's outdoorsy anything
that requires some sort of challenge and
anything my kids enjoy as well troit
congratulations we appreciate the
relationship over the years making
yourself available to come on the
program and we always learn something
when you come on so thank you very much
and happy birthday coming up I believe
in April oh thank you look forward to
our following conversation to the
trilogy here all right Thank You Troy
that's Troy Polamalu going into the Hall
of Fame turns 39 in April for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]